صراعات على الحدود تنتقل لتصبح
صراعا على سيادة العالم. انتهى
زمن الوقوف بعيدا وحان وقت
المنافسة. هم لا يتنافسون فقط في
التعداد السكاني الاكبر في
العالم فقط. الفيل الهندي في
مواجهة تنين الصيني. بكين تمتلك
الجو والهند تتحصن برا. لكن
كتنافس اهم من ذلك بكثير. انها
خارطة العالم الجديد يا سادة.
الهند تدخل هذا الماراثون. نعم
انها معركة النفس الطويل ضد ثاني
اقوى اقتصاد في العالم. فهل
يستطيع احفاد غاندي مضاهاة
الصينيين? ولماذا تدعم الولايات
المتحدة الهند لتقف في وجه
الصين. نادي القوى العظمى.
اندلعت حرب في اوكرانيا. وها نحن
ذا يا اصدقاء امام القوى
العالمية العظمى راحت نحو صراع
استراتيجي من نوع اخر. لتجد
الولايات المتحدة ضالتها في
الهند. هذا العملاق السكاني
والاقتصادي القوي والذي يتطور
بصورة مرعبة وخارقة للعادة.
الامريكان يراقبون بحذر التفوق
الديموغرافي للصين وروسيا.
ويحاولون تشكيل التوازن المقابل
من ثلاث قوى بشرية اساسية في
اسيا بقيادة الهند. لتتبعها
باكستان واندونيسيا. لتعود الهند
للواجهة العالمية بعد ان عقودا
من التوهان. فهل حان الوقت لعبور
هذه المراحل للوصول للقمة يا
هؤلاء؟ الهند على الطريق السليم.
وما حقيقة كخيال؟ فتأثير الهنود
الاستراتيجي في هذه الازمة اعلى
بكثير من بريطانيا العظمى التي
احتلتها لفترة طويلة. حتى انها
اصبحت اكثر دولة في العالم سعت
القوى الكبرى التي تدير الصراع
الاستراتيجي في الحرب الاوكرانية
الى كسب صفها وضمها الى جانبها.
لكن ما الذي تملكه الهند لتنضم
لقائمة تضم امريكا وروسيا
والصين؟ لها اكبر جيش في العالم
من حيث العدد الذي يصل لقرابة
خمسة ملايين بين الجنود الناشطين
وجنود الاحتياط بحسب جلوبال فاير
باور وهو بذلك رابع اقوى جيش في
العالم من حيث العدة والعتاد
والميزانية. ليحل في المرتبة
الثانية في القارة الاسيوية بعد
الجيش الصيني. بل ان الهند هي
ثالث اكبر دولة من حيث الانفاق
العسكري العالم بحسب معهد
ستوكهولم الدولي لابحاث السلام.
واضعة نصب عينيها الصين منافستها
الكبرى التي تشاركها حدودا
متنازعا عليها في جبال
الهيمالايا. مهلا مهلا. هنا
اشتباك بدأ بالايدي ثم انتقل
للعصي والهراوات. ولكن لم يصل
للاسلحة. انها اول مواجهة دموية
بين الطرفين في المنطقة. كان ذلك
منذ خمسة واربعين عاما. ويا له
من صراع ممتد منذ عقود. وعلى اثر
هذا الصراع حدث اشتباك في يناير
من عام الفين وواحد وعشرين.
ليترك جنود الجرحى لدى كلا
الجانبين. هدأت المناوشات وانسحب
الطرفان. لكن كل منهما يصب جام
تركيزه على تطوير جيشه العسكري.
وبمقارنة بسيطة بين الجارين
تحاول الهند اللحاق بالصين على
صعيد الانفاق العسكري. وزادت
ميزانيتها العسكرية لتصبح نحو
ثلاثة وسبعين مليار دولار. في
حين تظل الصين في المرتبة
الثانية عالميا. وقد زادت
ميزانية الدفاع بنسبة سبعة في
المائة لتصبح قرابة مائتين وخمسة
وعشرين مليار دولار. ولان
الارقام اصدق انباء عن الواقع في
اغلب الاحيان اليكم اهم
الاحصائيات العسكرية للبلدين حيث
اجمالي عدد الرؤوس النووية التي
تمتلكها الصين في عام الفين
وتسعة عشر كان يبلغ مائتين
وتسعين رأسا. لكنها في غضون عام
واحد ارتفعت الى ثلاثمائة
وخمسين. اما الهند فكان لديها
نحو مائة وثلاثين رأسا حربيا قبل
ثلاثة ثم زادت الى مائة وخمسين
رأسا وهذه الارقام وفقا لتقديرات
معهد ستوكهولم الدولي لابحاث
السلام المنشورة. اما المنافسة
العادلة بين البلدين فاستطاعت
الهند التفوق بها لتصبح اكبر
دولة في العالم من حيث عدد
السكان. اما المعلومة التي
ستسمعونها ربما لاول مرة فهي ان
حوالي تسعة عشر في المائة من
سكان العالم يعيشون في هاتين
الدولتين. اي ان كل دولة منهما
بحجم قارة. اي عدد مهول نتحدث.
هنا وفي مطلع عام الفين وثلاثة
وعشرين تفوقت الهند للمرة الاولى
على الصين من حيث عدد السكان.
ليصل العدد الهندي حاليا نحو
مليار واربعمائة وثلاثة وعشرين
مليون نسمة. مقابل مليار
واربعمائة واحد عشر مليون شخص في
الصين وفق وكالة الاناضول.
وبينما تم الاعلان ان عدد سكان
العالم وصل ثمانية مليارات شخص
مقابل سبعة وسبعة من عشرة مليارا
عام الفين تسعة عشر وفق دراسة
للمعهد الوطني للدراسات
الديموغرافية في فرنسا. فهل كانت
الزيادة في الهند يا ترى? مصنع
العالم. مركز التصنيع للعالم او
مصنع العالم مصطلح من كلمتين.
ولكنه يختزل في معناه السيطرة
على العالم حرفيا. كما تفعل
الصين حاليا. لكن هذه الغاية
صارت مشتركة اليوم بعد ان دخل
الهنديون على الخط في خضم الحديث
عن النزاعات الحدودية الدامية.
وعقد المقارنة العسكرية واستشراف
الافاق الاقتصادية وركود ما بعد
جائحة كورونا التي ضربت اقتصاد
البلدين مثلما فعلت في بقية
العالم. فبعد جائحة كورونا اخذت
الشركات العالمية تميل الى ترك
الصين والبحث عن مكان اخر. في ظل
القيود التي يفرضها الحزب
الشيوعي الصيني. اضافة الى سياسة
صفر كوفيد التي كلفت الشركات
كثيرا. وهل هناك مكان مناسب اكثر
من الهند كانت نيودلهي تتحين
فرصة لملء فراغ بكين بمجرد ان
تتراجع الصين عن موقعها
باعتبارها مصنع العالم. لكن هذا
الامر الصعب جدا. فخطوط الانتاج
والامداد اكثر تعقيدا بكثير مما
يتصور كثيرون. ومن العسير جدا
تفكيكها بين ليلة وضحاها. ومن
الصعوبة اعادة توطينها في مكان
مختلف بالسرعة المتخيلة لدى
البعض. وفق صحيفة فاينن انشال
تايمز. بينما هي فرصة كبيرة
للهند في عالم ما بعد الجائحة
رفاق. لكن يبقى ان نؤكد ان ضجيج
المناوشات الحدودية لا ينبغي ان
يغطي على الحقائق الاقتصادية.
فالصين هي ثاني اكبر شريك تجاري
للهند بعد الولايات المتحدة.
فالهند تميل الى تصدير المواد
الخام او المكونات الى قطاع
التصنيع الصيني. وتستورد في
المقابل المزيد من المنتجات
النهائية ذات القيمة المضافة
الاعلى. وبينما تميل كفة التبادل
التجاري بقوة لصالح الصين تجد
الهند نفسها تعتمد اعتمادا كبيرا
على جارة اللدود ويا لها من
حاجة. حيث تعطي الهند المواد
الخام للصين ثم تأخذها سلعا
جاهزة. وهكذا كان الحال ولا
يزال. لكن دوام الحال من المحال.
فنيودله ستصنع بنفسها من موادها
الخام مستقبلا. اذا استطاعت
الهند تحويل الانفجار السكاني
الى نقطة قوة عبر قطاع تكنولوجيا
المعلومات الذي باتت تنافس فيه
بقوة الولايات المتحدة والصين.
يلا بنا ندخل على. كما يقول
المصري وعلى حين غفلة من الصين
نفضت الهند غبار سباتها لتخصص
نحو مئة تريليون روبية اي واحد
واثنين من عشرة تريليون دولار
تقريبا لمشروع ضخم يقوم على
انشاء منصة رقمية تضم ستة عشرة
وزارة لتسريع مشروعات البنية
التحتية لجذب الاستثمارات
الخارجية خاصة من المصانع التي
ترغب في مغادرة الصين. والهدف هو
اختيار الشركات العالمية لهندي
كمركز تصنيع خاص بها بحسب وكالة
بلومبرج. وهنا ما يمنح الهند
ميزة اخرى عن الصين. فالصين ظلت
مغلقة الى حد كبير امام العالم
الخارجي في اطارات سياسة صفر
كوفيد. والشركات تبحث للتوسع
فيها او الشراء منها لتنويع
اعمالها والامدادات. وهنا وفرت
الهند وهي ثالث اكبر اقتصاد في
اسيا العمالة الرخيصة والعمال
الناطقين باللغة الانجليزية.
فالطريقة الوحيدة للتنافس مع
الصين هي ان تكون منافسا من حيث
التكلفة الامكان وهو ما تحاول
الهند تطبيقه حرفيا. وعلى ذكر
الشركات العالمية هنا شركة ابل
التي تخطط الان لبدء انتاج هاتف
ايفون اربعة عشر في الهند بعد
حوالي شهرين من الاصدار الاولي
للمنتج من الصين. وكانت ابل قد
انتجت نحو سبعة ونصف ملايين جهاز
ايفون في الهند العام الماضي
تمثل ثلاثة في المئة تقريبا من
الانتاج الاجمالي للشركة. نارين
دار مودي رئيس الوزراء الهندي
يعلنها صريحة ان بلاده تتجه
تحسين بنيتها التحتية بشكل كبير.
والواقع يشهد على ذلك. ومع
الحديث عن ايلاء الهند المزيد من
الاهتمام للتخزين الحديث ورقمنة
العمليات والعمالة الماهرة وخفض
تكاليف الخدمات اللوجيستية
وتوافر كل تلك العوامل سيجعل
الشركات تتجه للهند لبناء
مصانعها وبدء الانتاج فيها.
لتصبح الهند خليفة للصين كمصنع
للعالم. برأيكم